[Music]
the Ohm's law in simple words gives us
the relationship between the current the
voltage and the resistance in a circuit
this tells us that the flow of current
is directly proportional to the
potential difference between the points
and inversely proportional to the
resistance if the potential difference
between two points is more the current
flowing through it will be more and if
the resistance is more the current
flowing through it will be lesser this
is assuming that the other factors are
constant let's do a quick activity to
understand Ohm's law we would need a
nichrome wire a voltmeter and ammeter
and three electric cells of very low
voltages somewhere in the range of 1 to
1.5 volts first we form a circuit like
this which has just one cell as the
source this is the nichrome via which is
the resistance also this is the ammeter
which is in series this is the voltmeter
which is connected in parallel and this
is the plucky we close the plucky and
note down a few readings we need to note
on the reading in the ammeter and the
reading in the voltmeter let the current
and the potential difference be I 1 and
V 1 respectively in the second case
connect two cells in the circuit and
note the respective readings of the
ammeter and the voltmeter
don't forget the ammeter gives the value
of current through the nichrome wire and
the voltmeter gives the potential
difference across the nichrome wire
let's say the readings are I 2 and V 2
respectively and then repeat the same
procedure for the third case when three
cells are used as the source you will
notice that as the number of cells
increases the current as well as the
voltage increase but are they increasing
proportionally to know that we add an
additional column at the right which
calculates the value of V over I for
each case you will notice that the ratio
of potential difference to the current
in each case will approximately be equal
this
tells us that the potential difference V
across the ends of a wire is directly
proportional to the current flowing
through it this relationship was
discovered by a German physicist Georg
Simmel
ohm in the earth 1827 noticed that the
resistance here is constant and we also
assume that all other factors including
temperature are also constant this is
the Ohm's law if V is directly
proportional to I it also means that V
over I is constant and that constant is
nothing but R or the resistance what is
resistance it is simply the property of
a conductor to resist the flow of
charges through it here in this
experiment it was constant the SI units
of voltage and current are volt and
ampere respectively but what's the SI
unit of resistance its ohm and is
represented by this Greek letter if the
potential difference across two ends of
a conductor is 1 volt and the current
through it is 1 ampere then the
resistance of the conductor will be one
arm in the next video we will look at
another interesting experiment to
understand the on floor
[Music]